أعني أن الحشود قد غادرت الآن
منطقة ألير حيث نحن خارج
مكتب البلدية حيث رأينا تلك
الحشود. كان أفراد الأسرة متجمعين في وقت سابق
ينتظرون لساعات طوال
اليوم بفارغ الصبر لمعرفة ما إذا
كان أحبائهم مدرجين في قائمة
الأسماء  تم إطلاق سراحهم اليوم والذي استغرق وقتًا
أطول قليلاً مما رأيناه فعليًا
ليلة الجمعة، ولكن بالطبع
رأينا الآن هؤلاء المعتقلين والسجناء الفلسطينيين الـ 39
أطلق سراح العديد منهم،
وكان 33 منهم على الأقل أطفالًا قاصرين
تقل أعمارهم عن 18 عامًا ورأيناهم
يحملهم الناس على الأكتاف في
الشارع إلى مقر البلدية أه
حيث كانوا محاطين بآلاف
الأشخاص الذين تجمعوا أكثر من
ألف بل تجمعوا
للترحيب بهم للاحتفال بإطلاق سراحهم
من المعتقلات المهم ملاحظة أن
أغلبية هؤلاء الأطفال  الذين
تم إطلاق
سراحهم كانوا محتجزين إداريًا، مما يعني عدم
توجيه أي تهم إليهم، ولا توجد
إجراءات قانونية جارية، وقد
تحدثنا إلى العديد من العائلات هنا، حيث
كان العديد منهم ينتظرون خارج
مكتب البلدية حتى قبل
معرفة ما إذا كان أطفالهم سينجبون أم لا
سيكون أحبائهم على القائمة التي
كانوا ينتظرونها على أمل أن
يأتي اليوم بأخبار إيجابية لهم،
وكان بعضهم محظوظًا بالفعل بما يكفي لرؤية
أطفالهم يطلق سراحهم اليوم أه العديد من
الأشخاص الذين تحدثنا إليهم مع الأطفال
الذين تم احتجازهم والآن  المفرج عنهم
تحدثوا عن تجربتهم في
الاحتجاز مدى صعوبة الأمر بالنسبة
لهم خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية مع عدم وجود
معلومات عن الإجراءات القانونية التي
كانوا يمرون بها تحدثنا مع أه
شاب سام التميمي عمره 17
أه صبي هو  تم إطلاق سراحه الليلة وتحدث
عن الشهرين الأخيرين اللذين
قضاهما أه في السجن
ووصف ذلك بأنه أحد
أصعب التجارب في حياته لكنه
قال إنه كان سعيدًا فقط بالعودة إلى المنزل ليكون
مع عائلته وفي النهاية
الحصول على طهي والدته في المنزل مرة أخرى الآن
بالطبع هذا جزء من إطلاق سراح أوسع
للمعتقلين والسجناء الفلسطينيين
كجزء من اتفاقية الهدنة بين
إسرائيل وحماس والتي نرى ما
يقرب من 150 معتقلًا
وسجينًا فلسطينيًا تم إطلاق سراحهم خلال
فترة الهدنة التي استمرت 4 أيام  إذا تم بالفعل الالتزام بشروط
التهدئة مقابل إطلاق سراح ما
لا يقل عن 50 رهينة إسرائيلية من المقرر
إطلاق سراحهم من أسر حماس في غزة
كما رأينا اليوم مجموعة أخرى أه من
الرهائن الإسرائيليين أه تم إطلاق سراحهم اليوم
من قبل حماس لكن بالطبع لا يوجد  في ظل وجود الكثير
من الوضوح بشأن من سيتم إطلاق سراحه
على الجانب الفلسطيني أو على
الجانب الإسرائيلي، فسوف ننتظر يومًا بعد يوم للحصول على
هذه التفاصيل، ولكن بالطبع هناك
أسئلة حول الاتهامات التي
واجهها العديد من هؤلاء الفلسطينيين
في وقت سابق من الأسبوع.  لقد رأيت قائمة أولية
أصدرتها السلطات الإسرائيلية تضم
حوالي 300 اسم للأشخاص الذين سيكونون
مؤهلين للإفراج المحتمل،
وكان العديد منهم مرة أخرى قاصرين تحت سن
18 عامًا وبالطبع من بين التهم التي وجهها
الكثير منهم كانت غالبيتها
جرائم بسيطة بما في ذلك  أه بما في ذلك أه
رشق الحجارة على الجنود الإسرائيليين
وأيضا أه التهديد بالمخاطرة
بالأمن الإقليمي كانوا الأكثر شيوعا
من بين تلك التهم بالطبع مع
الناس هنا في الضفة الغربية المحتلة
هذه لحظة راحة كبيرة
ومرحب بها للكثيرين منهم